Marvel's two guardians of the galaxy
installments are action-packed exciting
and even meaningful best of all they're
really funny usually that humor is
intentional but sometimes it's a
complete accident
which is great because these bloopers
make us love guardians of the galaxy
even more Rooker books it you think
walking and chewing gum at the same time
as hard try walking and talking sure it
sounds like something you do every day
but as actors Michael Rooker and Tom
Proctor prove here it's not always as
easy as it seems
he was cargo and you always go soft on
you walked us right off the set yes I
can come on I'm going to do it again
a blooper from a galaxy far far away
Kurt Russell is a living legend but even
legends sometimes screw up their lines
like in this blooper where Russell
accidentally gives a shout-out to the
franchise that inspired much of the
space action in guardians of the galaxy
well even where I reside out past the
edge of what's known we've heard tell
about the man they call Star Wars in
trouble danced off in space in the
theatrical ending to the first film
Chris Pratt star-lord uses the threat of
a dance-off as a diversion but in this
awesome outtake Lee paces bad guy Ronan
the accuser accepts the challenge
leading to the epic showdown we've all
been waiting for it's on
[Music]
wirework gone haywire the guardians of
the galaxy movies take place on various
planets with varying levels of gravity
to make it look realistic the actors
have to strap themselves in for some
wire work sometimes the results are
amazing and other times this happens
[Music]
rock it to the gag reel Groot and Rocket
Raccoon are the result of the combined
magic of CGI the voice work of stars Vin
Diesel and Bradley Cooper and motion
capture and thank goodness the movies
used real life human stand-ins for the
tree man and his trash panda buddy
because how else would a blooper
featuring these two characters even be
possible nonsense
here's a blooper stuffed take that made
its way into the final cut of guardians
of the galaxy while dealing with a rare
goods dealer known as the broker
yondu frustrates and upsets the guy by
mumbling a bunch of gibberish it's a
little more than co-star Sean Gunn could
handle and director James Gunn kept the
result in the film the high-end
community is of any more nonsense
it's apparently no sweat for Michael
Rooker to make up his own real sounding
nonsense words in a pinch but give the
guy some comic book slash science
fiction movie dialogue heavy on the
technical side and he just can't get the
words out without stumbling Lee pace
loses his place prior to joining the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Lee pace
worked primarily as an actor in more
straightforward dramas those roles
didn't necessarily prepare him for the
bonkers role of Ronan the accuser as
this blooper of pace struggling to nail
the roll shows wait one more time was
that so yeah then turn
power becomes the only law this alright
is it Chris Pratt doing surround finally
the encounter between the guardians of
the galaxy and the alien ruler Aisha
drives much of the conflict in the
second film what could have all gone
very differently if star-lord had gotten
his way he didn't but at least the
effort left us with this amazing gym
I personally control half the DNA by
doing something I called Duncan thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]